يتشعب الصراع الامريكي الصيني من حدود
السماء وحتى باطن الارض وياخذ عده اشكال
الان هو على شكل ايقونه موسيقيه في جوالنا
اسمه يدق في اروقه الكونغرس الذي اطلق
عدوى الخوف الى اوروبا والكثير من الدول
للاستعداد واخذ الحيطه تيك توك ليس ازمه
جديده لكنها تتفاقم تراه الولايات المتحده
خطرا الاتحاد الاوروبي وغيرهما ربما لن
تحدث دولا كثيره حذو الهند التي حضرت
تطبيق تماما في 2020 لكن الخطوات تذهب
بذلك بذات الاتجاه على الاقل على صعيد
اجهزه الحكومات المفوضيه الاوروبيه مجلس
الاتحاد الاوروبي البرلمان الاوروبي اجهزه
الحكومه الكنديه الامريكيه وظفوا الحكومه
ونواف الدنمارك وهولندا تتجه لحظر التطبيق
على اجهزه موظفيها
هذه القائمه الطويله الخوف يتسلل الى
بريطانيا لكن التعاطي مع الخطر يحتمل
تاجيل لاغراض انتخابيه
قد يكون الهوس بمنصه تيك توك قد وصل حد
الجنون بين افراد الجيل الجديد في
بريطانيا حيث يتجاوز عدد مستخدميه اكثر من
عشره ملايين لكنه بات هما ومصدر قلق لا
ينتهي للحكومات الغربيه ومنها بريطانيا
التي احتارت كيف تتعامل مع تطبيق الصيني
فبعد فض قيود على استخدام التطبيق بين
السياسيين والموظفين الحكوميين في كل من
الولايات المتحده واوروبا لاسباب تتعلق
بالامن السيبراني لم تحدد بريطانيا موقفها
من التطبيق بعد هي اعتبرت ان قرار استخدام
التطبيق يعود لحريه اختيار النواب
والوزراء الذين لا يزال عدد كبير منهم
يستخدم التطبيق لجذب الناخبين الصغار قبيل
الانتخابات المجمعه نهايه العام المقبل
الاعتراض على تيك توك يعود الى القلق من
تجسس الاستخبارات الصينيه على المسؤولين
الغربيين من خلال التطبيق لكن الصين تحاول
اقناع بريطانيا بعدم السير على خطى اوروبا
والولايات المتحده اذ من المخطط ان يقدم
المستشار العام لتيك توك ايجازا الاسبوع
المقبل في وسمينستر لشرح مدى سلامه
استخدام التطبيق فهل ستقتنع بريطانيا
اذا تيك توك يتجه الى ان يكون ممنوعا من
التسلل اكثر لكن هي حقيقه ان وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي كلها متهمه بانتهاك
الخصوصيه والمتاجره بالبيانات وكثيرا ما
تعرضت لدفع غرامات كتلك التي دفعتها ميثا
وجوجل للاتحاد الاوروبي فلماذا الحظر لتيك
توك بالذات اولا التطبيق اعترف نهايه
العام الماضي اجرت بيض دانس تحقيقا حول
مراقبه صحفي مجله فوربز والاتقاء التجسس
عليهم وذلك على اثر التحقيق طرد كريس
لبيتاك كبير المراجعين الداخليين في
بايدنز الذي قاد عمليه التجسس واستقاله
ايضا المدير التنفيذي للشركه سونغي الذي
قدمت اليه تفاصيل العمليه الاعتراف كان
بمراسلات رسميه لتيك توك مع المجله حاله
فرديه ربما غير ان خلفها هناك ما اججج قلق
الحكومات الغربيه من التطبيق ومن خلفه
الاستخبارات الصينيه وما يعزز المخاوف
وجود قانون صيني دخل حيز التنفيذ في 2016
قانون تحت مسمى مكافحه الارهاب يفرض على
شركات الانترنت العامله في الصين تسليم
مفاتيح التشفير وكلمات المرور للحكومه
الصينيه عند الطلب الحق القانون باخر دخل
حيز التنفيذ في 2017 يتيح الرقابه لصيقه
على بيانات المستخدمين وتخزينها في
الشركات العامله في الصين بناء عليه تحذر
تقارير امنيه امريكيه بالنف الصين نظريا
يمكنها استخدام البيانات للتجسس على
المستخدمين الافراد ومراقبه انشطتهم
ومواقعهم من خلال الاي بي ادرس عمليا هذا
ما حدث في اكتوبر الماضي مع صحفي المجله
مج له فولكس ويتصاعد الخوف على سلم الخطر
الامريكي الى حد استخدام الصين لكل
المعلومات لديها في مهاجمه الولايات
المتحده بحملات توزعزع استقرار البلاد
ولهذا جاء حظر التطبيق على اجهزه موظفي
الادارات الحكوميه خلال مده اقصاها 30
يوما لكن هناك استثناءات
امر البيت الابيض الوكالات الفيدراليه بان
تحضر في غضون 30 يوما تطبيق تيك توك على
هواتفها واجهزتها بسبب مخاطره على الامن
القومي الامريكي الا ان مذكره صادره عن
مكتب الاداره والميزانيه في البيت الابيض
تعطي استثناءات محدوده قد تصل مدتها الى
عام واحد لوكالات انشطه انفاذ القانون
ومصالح وانشطه الامن القوميه والبحوث
الامنيه لكن على هذه الوكالات ان تقتصر
باستعمال الاستثناءات على الحالات التي
يكون فيها استخدام تيك توك امرا بالغ
الاهميه لمهمتها وعندما تكون الطرق
البديله غير قابله للتطبيق كما يسمح
للوكالات الامنيه باستخدامه للتحقيق وتمنح
الاستثناءات من قبل رئيس الوكاله او من
ينوب عنه بعدما يقرر بان الاستخدام ستكون
له علاقه واضحه بمصالح او انشطه الامن
القوميه